[Musica]
lì bot
all'inizio degli anni settanta nasce nel
bronx e permetteva ragazzi afroamericani
e latinoamericani spesso emarginati di
interagire tra loro comporre musica e
sentirsi liberi a cinquant'anni di
distanza un gruppo musicale il rap
agains di the tall ship tramite i brani
pubblicati su internet stanno
denunciando i soprusi che il governo
militare thailandese sta perpetrando nei
confronti della popolazione
a dispetto di una inefficace censura
questo evento potrebbe influire
drasticamente sulle prossime elezioni in
thailandia
dieci anni fa in una mailing list di
crittografi un utente sotto lo
pseudonimo di satoshi nakamoto condivide
un documento bitcoin appears to peer
electronic cash system all'interno di
quel documento tra le fondamenta che
permettevano a bitcoin di funzionare
abbiamo l'innovazione della block chain
ma che cos'è questa innovazione di cui
sentiamo tutti parlare che continuano a
ripetere che cambierà il mondo
immaginate di avere un'informazione di
voler rendere questa informazione è
immutabile
contestualmente di voler verificare in
maniera istantanea l'integrità di questa
informazione di attribuire a questa
informazione è una data certa e di
essere certi che il possesso di questa
informazione sia in mano vostra ora
quest'ultimo concetto soprattutto e
ossimorico se si pensa al concetto di
informazione che per sua natura è
infinitamente replicabile e duplicabile
come possiamo riappropriarci
dell'informazione vi chiederei di fare
come un piccolo esperimento ognuno in
sala lo pregherei di tramite
l'applicazione note del proprio
cellulare segnare delle informazioni che
condivideremo così come io segnerò
alcune informazioni vi prego di
replicare
fedelmente tutti sappiamo che la fila
uno è occupata lo possiamo vedere però
senza vedere in faccia e chiedere
un'identificazione formale alla persona
seduta nella fila a al posto 1 non
possiamo essere certi della sua identità
quindi sotto lo pseudonimo di a1 che io
vado a scrivere sul mio cellulare vi
prego di fare altrettanto a fianco in
magazziniere mondato ora signora se per
favore mi vuole dire un numero ipotetico
immaginario che però faremo finta
rappresenti il saldo del suo conto
corrente
prego ok allora io sto segnando 25 così
come vi prego di fare altrettanto
ora stessa cosa la possiamo fare per il
posto occupato della persona in a2
prego ottimo ora io
potremmo continuare all'infinito tanto
fino a riempire i posti di questa sala
ora nel mio registro è presente
l'informazione che è in a1
c'è una foto lo pseudonimo 1 o 25 unità
siamo tutti sincronizzati abbiamo tutti
queste informazioni sui nostri
smartphone
inseriamo una dinamica sociale adesso
ipotizziamo che io sia un ente centrale
se l'informazione che ho registrato sul
mio cellulare è un unità di conto
facciamogli euro come abbiamo ipotizzato
nel caso del saldo del conto corrente
allora rivestirò il ruolo di banca
centrale se invece avesse registrato una
proprietà immobiliare allora rivestire
il ruolo di catasto quindi diciamo che
io sono lente centrale a questa
informazione
io ho il potere di fare tutto ciò che la
legge mi consente di fare del tipo una
patrimoniale posso sottrarre 5 unità di
valore da ogni singolo account presente
addebitarle accreditarle su un altro
account e di conseguenza
parla al totale oppure potrei applicare
un pignoramento ti può azzerare il
valore dell'account a2 voi tutti saresti
obbligati a sincronizzare i vostri
registri a seconda delle informazioni
presenti sul mio
siamo tutti abituati a dialogare con
enti centrali sotto diversi profili essi
controllano e hanno il possesso dei
nostri dati li affidiamo le nostre
proprietà
siamo stati abbastanza fortunati nella
società in cui viviamo non abbiamo avuto
grandi scompensi ma lo stesso non
possono dire i contadini dell'honduras
ad esempio che nel 2014 hanno visto
comparire dei certificati di proprietà
delle loro terre però intestati a
persone diverse compagnie private
la block chain a un sistema diverso di
consenso che si regge su un paradigma
l'assenza totale di fiducia non vi
dovete fidare di un ente centrale perché
i detentori dell'informazione
quindi noi tutti che abbiamo segnato sui
nostri dispositivi
il registro siamo parte dello stesso
funzionamento
questo avviene grazie delle regole
matematiche che ora proveremo a vedere
insieme
entriamo più nel dettaglio grazie a un
applicativo di andreas broward che
ringraziamo un applicativo che possiamo
trovare sul web
qui vedete più o meno replicato quello
di cui stavamo parlando prima rispetto
alla count a uno i saldi qui sono
ipotetici potremmo aggiornarli notate
che l'ex ossia quel numero di fatto è un
numero espresso in formato esadecimale
enorme cambia a seconda che io vado a
cambiare l'informazione presente qui in
bianco se aggiungo anche solo uno spazio
cosa che ho appena fatto
l'impronta digitale cambia questa
impronta digitale mi garantisce che le
informazioni qui presenti sono
registrate e sono quelli in maniera
univoca
andiamo ad aggiungere qualche
informazione di ingresso
giusto per avere qualche altro dato il
numero di blocco
questa impronta digitale 91 49 viene
restituita a secondo perché ho un numero
in ingresso del blocco o i dati da me
inseriti e poi notate che c'è non so se
un numero occasionale e ora ci diamo una
regola matematica tutti quanti decidiamo
che questo blocco per essere valido deve
avere quattro zeri
all'inizio chiediamo al computer di
trovare un numero occasionale che
insieme ai dati che abbiamo messo rivali
di questa regola
questo rende la validità del blocco
appena io andrò a modificare
l'informazione quel numero occasionale
non sarà più valido non andrà più bene
avrò bisogno di un nuovo numero
occasionale che mi ridia un'impronta
digitale valida
notiamo però che quelle impronte
digitale con quattro zeri è diversa di
volta in volta questa inizia quattro
zeri 63 la nostra impronta digitale
originaria e con quattro zeri 46
eccetera sono tutte impronte digitali
diverse perché hanno all'origine dati
diversi blog chen però significa catena
di blocchi abbiamo una catena come la
costruiamo mettendo tra i dati di input
l'impronta digitale del blocco
precedente qui ad esempio nel blocco 1 e
nel blocco 2 a 4
quindi l'utente seduto in a4 ha
effettuato un pagamento nei confronti
dell'utente a 5 ha ceduto 7 unità di
valore quelle sette unità di valore
potrebbero essere tranquillamente 7
bitcoin che è a quel punto ci
chiederebbero una validazione
e il sistema mi restituisce un numero di
non occasionale che permette al blocco
di essere validato perché questa cosa è
fondamentale perché nel momento stesso
in cui a quattro che un ente malevolo
volesse riappropriarsi dei suoi sette
bitcoin la cosa che andrebbe a fare è
modificare il dato archiviato sulla
glock gen
quindi togliendo lo zero e rimettendosi
il 7 dovrebbe ri minare il blocco ma i
blocchi successivi continuerebbero
essere invalidi perché perché le
impronte digitale che vi era archiviata
e diversa dalla nuova impronta digitale
che è il blocco due quindi con
l'operazione malevola gli sta provando a
dare a quattro però potrebbe essere un
ente centrale potrebbe solamente
certificato potrebbe avere un infinità
potenza di calcolo potrebbe avere la
voglia e le capacità tecniche di
ricostruire tutta la block con la sua
operazione malevola
proviamo a farlo quindi il blocco in a4
anche nel blocco 3 verrà riportata la
nuova informazione verrà ritrovato
questo numero occasionale il blocco avrà
una nuova impronta digitale valida ma
c'è un problema il problema del consenso
a quattro è solo uno degli utenti che ha
la copia della block chain la stessa
block chain e distribuita è presente in
tutti gli operatori presenti all'interno
della rete
quindi mentre a quattro si sta dannando
l'anima per cercare di portare a
compimento la sua operazione malevola
con una potenza di calcolo infinita nel
minor tempo possibile
subito gli altri operatori della blixen
diranno non se la maggioranza se solo un
attore di tutti noi e quindi al secondo
0 estro metteranno l'operatore malevolo
ora
abbiamo detto che l'informazione è il
segreto
ora proviamo proviamo a questo punto a
immagazzinare un'informazione se mi dice
anche il suo nome per favore creiamo il
numero un numero esadecimale che in
realtà verrà inserito all'interno di una
transazione nella block chain di bitcoin
lo sto facendo da linea di codice ma può
essere creato da diversi applicativi
data
è stata inserita all'interno della
blocks in questo numero è un numero
identificativo che io posso inserire in
un qualsiasi blocco explorer e chiedere
all'interno della bluocean di bitcoin di
restituirmi di restituirmi
l'informazione è perfettamente arrivata
saluti da paola dal decs vari saloni
[Applauso]
[Musica]